です皆さんは学校生活小学わかんないまだ
学校行ってない人いたらごめんねでも基本
的にみんなは小学校だったり中学校だっ
たり高校だったり学校で生活してる人した
ことある人たくさんいると思うんです
けれどもこう自分の中で特別な体験だっ
たりこういうことをすごいことがあった
みたいなニュースみたいな事件ってあり
ますでしょうかなんか俺ふと学生時代
どんな感じだったんだろうって思い返した
時に
よく考えたらやばいことがあったなと思っ
て結構
衝撃的な事件みたいなことが1回あったん
ですけれどもそれちょっと皆さんに紹介し
たくて動画化してみましたのでそちらを
ご覧くださいはいでそれにこうタイトルを
つけるとしたら
失神というタイトルです
僕の名前は
枝はじめ高校1年生のバスケットボール部
バスケットボールはちょっとだけ上手くて
高校1年生の時からスタメン入りそのせい
でちょっとだけ目立っていたけど学校では
平穏な生活を送っているぜみんなよろしく
なこいつの名前は筋肉ムキムキのすけ高校
2年生のバスケ部の先輩ちょっとだけ怖い
先輩なんだこいつはモブ同じクラスの同級
生わりと一緒にいることが多いぜ部活に
おいて一番大事なことそれは先輩に
気に入られることさ
始めてはい先輩から頼まれれば俺はパンで
も何でもすぐ買いに行ってた
[音楽]
先輩が疲れている様子だったら俺はすぐに
でも肩を揉みに行ってた先輩に好かれる
ためだったら俺は何だってするぜ
俺が食べたい
[音楽]
先輩がバトルが見たいと言ったら俺は友達
でもバブルをしていた先輩がこれを見て
楽しんだったら俺は何だってするぜただ
こんなことやりたくはなかったけどね
[拍手]
大好きなお菓子も1000倍のためだっ
たらすぐあげるさ俺は先輩のためだったら
何だってするからね
そしてテストの日事件は起きた
やばいもうすぐテストだやばいよねどう
する本当に勉強何もしないこれ
[音楽]
お疲れ様ですなんとテスト直前にあの先輩
が俺たちの教室の前にやってきた俺たちは
ニコニコしていたが内心は自分の勉強しろ
よクソ野郎と思っていた
お前らテスト勉強大丈夫
いい感じだよないい感じ大丈夫です
めっちゃ深呼吸してめっちゃ深呼吸
トイレ行ってきます
[音楽]
テスト
頑張れよ
お疲れお
疲れ様です
はじめ始め
派手にやられちまってるよ俺は
失神してしまったモブに助けられながら
なんとか教室内
失神して保健室に行ったり帰宅してしまう
とテストが受けられないそんなことは俺の
選択肢にはなかった
[音楽]
おいどうせ大丈夫か大丈夫ですよかった
大丈夫かモブのおかげでなんとかバレずに
すんだありがとうボブ
ができません
健闘を祈る
そして最後のテストが始まる俺は
映らな記憶の中なんとか起きてテストを
受けなければその一心で心の中で
祈った
顔きれなかった
おいおいはじめ大丈夫テスト
終わったぞ大丈夫大丈夫
かテスト終わったテスト終わったお前
ずっと気絶してたぞ記憶ねえよ大丈夫保健
室行くえ何があった俺
できたばっちりでしたバッチリです
[笑い]
[拍手]
はいいかがだったでしょうか
やばいよ絶対真似しないでねあの本当に
そういう窒息ゲームっていうのなんか一
時期流行ったりだとかたまにニュースで
見るんですけども本当に危ないからマジで
やってはいけないですちょっと部分部分
盛りましたけども割とマジで実話に基づい
てる話でいやなんかねいるんですよこれ
学校あるあるかわかんないしみんなのある
あるかはわかんないけどそういうちょっと
すごい先輩みたいなのが絶対いるんですよ
ねその先輩にその先輩に捕まって
湿疹させられてそのまま英語のテストを
受けたっていう記憶があります
覚えてるか先輩
先輩
おい
後輩はあんな風にしちゃいけないだろう
先輩俺忘れてないですよテスト前に失神さ
せられたことを
許しましょうもうしないでくださいありえ
ん普通にというなかなかこう
令和にはなさそうな山事件があったんです
けどちょっとまた学ラン買ったしまだ
ちょっとみんなの面白い話とかも聞いてみ
たいのでコメント欄で学校のやば話とか
なんか教えてください
面白そうだったらワンチャン動画化して
あげよう皆さん学校生活安心安全だけども
ワクワクする
くださいじゃあ
[音楽]
いいねいいねいいね
大丈夫
いいね
[音楽]
[笑い]
めっちゃ良かったのに
マジでごめん